today on the matt well show what is the
left's real problem with the
anti-groomer efforts in florida and
across the country it's that we're
trying to get their religion out of the
school system a separation of the
leftist church and state you might say
also the by administration is claiming
that inflation is putin's price hike
we'll take a look at the data and see if
that claim holds up obviously it doesn't
plus desantis puts policies in place to
support fatherhood in florida which has
some leftists upset and a male prisoner
first identified as a woman and now
identifies as a baby and of course that
self-identity is being respected by
prison staff in our daily cancellation a
libertarian magazine laments the lack of
porn online apparently there isn't
enough of this stuff on the internet
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt wall show
[Music]
as we'll talk about um in the show today
inflation of course is out of control
and it's been it's been this way for a
while now then there's there's no
unfortunately there's no end currently
in sight especially with biden in the
white house and one area where we see
inflation more than ever is in the
grocery store prices for beef are only
going to get higher summer approaches
and your favorite cuts will be harder to
find you can lock in your price and
supply with good ranchers right now
that's the good news once you subscribe
your price never goes up making good
ranchers the best way to inflation proof
your meals shop good ranches for all of
your beef chicken and seafood needs good
ranchers only sells 100 american meat
from local farms and ranches they have
signature steak um uh burgers they have
uh their they have uh pre-trimmed and
pre-merited native chicken breasts which
are absolutely delicious and really easy
to repair and the great thing about the
chicken breast i'm always telling you
about is that uh you
it's like it doesn't matter what you do
they're not dry or anything they're
they're just great plus their packaging
makes it easy to cook what you want and
save the rest which keeps you from
wasting anything get your 30 discount on
prime steaks and better than organic
chicken today go to goodranchers.com
walsh to save on the equality that
you've been looking for good ranchers
takes the guesswork out of the grocery
store by sourcing everything from local
farms and shipping it to your door use
my code walsh and enjoy your box of 100
american meat and your 30 savings order
now to combat inflation with good
ranchers american meat delivered
you know it's not often that i say this
but a rather brilliant tweet from a
trans activist went viral yesterday it
was brilliant of course for none of the
reasons that the activists intended yet
in an entirely unintentional way i think
it raised a number of important points
worth considering in greater depth the
post which has been like nearly 100 000
times or so says this in reference to
the florida anti-groomer bill
i wonder how these conservatives would
feel if we passed a law making it
illegal to teach your kids about
religion until they were adults and then
the follow-up suggests a name for this
legislation which would be the don't say
bible bill
now the problem here right off the bat
is that it is already illegal for a
christian teacher in a public school to
teach their religion to the students a
teacher cannot stand in front of the
class and announce that jesus christ is
lord and savior and all students must
affirm this fact on their next exam or
else receive a failing grade
now any teacher who did such a thing and
no teacher would do that or is doing
anything like that but uh would be
promptly fired and most likely sued if
not worse
if the christian religion is
acknowledged at all in schools today it
is in the older grades as part of world
history the bible may be taught as
literature which makes sense given that
it's the most influential book in the
history of the world it's impossible to
fully understand and appreciate much of
classic literature if you don't know
anything about the bible because so many
of the themes and references and
everything come from the bible but even
that is rarely done in modern schools
now
the fact is that the christian religion
even as a even as a simple fact of
history and culture has been all but
erased from modern curriculum
i don't say this because i think it
ought to be that way i don't i'm simply
saying that it is that way which negates
the point made in the tweet but as noted
the argument does raise
a couple of crucial points inadvertently
especially because this is certainly not
the first time that someone on the left
has drawn this sort of comparison
and it's an enlightening comparison
because it again totally by accident
correctly situates lgbt ideology in its
place as a religion in its own right
it's a religion with its own sacred
texts its own priests and priestesses
its own traditions its own holy days of
obligation its own saints and martyrs
its own sacred symbols
its own notions of sin and virtue
its own story of redemption
it has its own god too which is the god
of the self
and it has its own sense of the
supernatural
souls who get trapped in the wrong body
and so forth very very
a very supernatural
spiritual kind of concept in fact you
can't you can't even begin you can't
understand gender ideology at all
because it's incoherent but you can't
even begin to understand you can't get
close to the proximity of understanding
what they're trying to say
um
unless you first
understand that this is a spiritual
claim that they're making that this is a
this is a this is a spiritual belief
system
and then you kind of get in the door
and then you're confused because it all
starts to break down but that's the kind
of thing we're dealing with
now the difference is that the leftist
religion
except in florida now
is taught in public school even in
florida it can still be taught outside
of the earliest grades and even in the
earliest grades it can still basically
be taught
it's taught not just as a cultural
reality but as an actual fact
that the children in school are required
to affirm the tenets of this religion
now i wouldn't have a problem actually
with the kids learning at an appropriate
age
about the lgbt religion as a cultural
reality
like being made to understand that the
dominant religion in the culture you
live is this and here's what it teaches
at a certain point you do have to
introduce your kids to that fact not
when they're in kindergarten
but they are entering into a a culture
that is
run according to this religion
for their own sake they should
understand a few things about it
that's not what's happening in schools
it's the the tenets of the religion are
to be affirmed by the kids they're made
to adopt its language observe its
traditions
pay reverence to his holy figures
they're indoctrinated into the faith
they're taught to a work to worship its
god which is the self or more accurately
the god they're made to worship is their
idea of the self because in the leftist
cult you don't so much worship your
actual self as your deluded perception
of yourself um
you kind of worship what you want
yourself to be self-worship in the
traditional sense is bad enough
but it's not even as bad as the sort of
self-worship that you find in the lgbt
religion because the latter is a
self-worship completely severed from
reality
from anything stabilizing or real
the adherent of this faith
worships a self that hardly even exists
psychologically and spiritually they're
floating in an abyss
untethered disoriented
in despair
which is why there's so much despair
especially among kids i was just i was
just
reading an article about
uh how the number of kids who who report
that they have persistent feelings of
hopelessness and sadness
and if you look at a chart which
measures this kind of thing you're going
to see that that number that line going
up and up and up
year after year after year
with all the recency bias that we have
these days people are going to look at
that and see all the kids that are
reporting that they're
feeling sad and hopeless and everything
and they're we're going to be told that
some of it's because of the pandemic and
certainly the lockdowns didn't help that
was a that was a you know a factor which
only made the situation worse
but this is a trend that goes
much farther back than that
it's not normal at least it shouldn't be
it is normal these days
to have so many kids that are
feeling hopeless and sad all the time
but it should not be normal
that is not actually normal especially
for kids
why are they feeling that way because
these are kids who have no sense of
direction no sense of purpose
they're in that abyss
no sense even of themselves
this is the kind of religious observance
that the left is desperately trying to
protect in schools
you know the schools have long since
become leftist religious institutions
like a bunch of you know bizarre
perverse sunday schools basically where
the public schools are now and that
brings us to the second crucial point
which was incidentally made by this
enlightening argument
um
the left took over the school system and
turned them into their own parochial
institutions at a time when
conservatives were busy telling
themselves ourselves
a story about this fanciful entirely
fictional thing called an unbiased
education
we tried to guard the neutrality of the
education system a neutrality that never
existed and can't exist while the left
was busy using the system to impart
their own value system
now we're finally awake enough to be
playing defense trying to purge some of
this leftist lunacy from the system
which is good but it is just defense
we will really be awake when we realize
that there is no such thing as a neutral
education
we should not be trying to go back to
the unbiased education that never
existed and can't exist
instead we should be educating our
children into our own value system our
own principles our own in this case
correct moral code
there is no such thing
as education divorced from values
even an education imparted by robots
couldn't achieve that because robots
have to be programmed by human beings
and as long as humans are involved there
will not be true neutrality
in the case of the education system
there shouldn't be
the ultimate purpose of education after
all is not simply to impart information
computers can do that
the purpose is the most fundamental
level moral formation is to shape and
guide our children
the left wants to shape them into
something deformed
shape them into something shapeless
and guide them into that abyss
it's our job
and we use education to do this to point
them in the right direction
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well talking about recency bias here's a
great example of it the biden
administration has settled on a name for
inflation
and uh what they're calling it is well
it's not inflation it's the
putin price hike this is what they're
going with and they've market tested it
they've focus grouped it and they've
decided this this is what it is it's all
putin's fault it's the putin price hike
uh here's jen pasaki
uh blaming all of the inflation we're
experiencing right now on
putin listen
so because of the actions we've taken to
address uh putin the putin price hike we
are in a better place than we were last
month um but we expect march cpa cpi
headline inflation to be extraordinarily
elevated due to putin's price hike and
we expect a large difference between
core and headline inflation reflecting
the global disruptions in energy and
food markets so chlorine inflation
doesn't include energy and food prices
uh headline inflation does and of course
we know that core inflation you know
energy the impact of energy of course on
oil prices gas prices we expect that to
uh continue to reflect what we've seen
uh the increases be over the course of
this invasion and just as an example
since president putin's military buildup
accelerated in january average gas
prices are up more than 80 cents most of
the increase in
occurred in the month of march and at
times gas prices were more than a dollar
above pre-invasion level so that roughly
25 percent increase in gas prices will
drive tomorrow's inflation reading and
certainly it's not a surprise to us but
we certainly think it will be reflected
so putin's price hike is what drives
inflation we're being told
and uh when putin you know launched this
current invasion which was back what
what did
early march
so really a few weeks ago
that's how i remember it anyway
and i i admit my memory is a little bit
foggy these days
but um here's
here's the interesting thing i found a
chart yesterday we'll put this up on the
screen
here's a chart uh tracking inflation
over the
over the last decade going back to 2011.
now again
memories foggy i'm also i'm not an
economist you know i i that's why i
don't i don't spend a lot of time
talking about issues like inflation um i
i leave that to people who know a little
bit more about these issues but even so
i mean maybe help me out here
um
did so you can see the line then you can
see kind of inflation data and this is
from the labor department this is you
know they're the ones who comprise all
this uh compile all this data
and you can kind of see i mean the line
when the lines go up that's bad right
that means inflation is that means
that's inflation rising am i am i am i
right about that do i know that much at
least even without a you know a degree
in economics
so
reading the graph
you can start to see
that upward trajectory really kick off
like a real and actually take off like a
rocket ship right at like the beginning
of 2021
is that when putin began his inv his
current invasion of ukraine
in the beginning was it like a year ago
that's not my memory
what happened i'm trying to think back
huh
look at that chart so what what happened
at the beginning of 2021
it wasn't it wasn't putin invading
ukraine for my memory but something else
happened right around that time when you
see that rocket ship take off to the
moon
and was that oh yeah that was uh that
was right when biden took office
that's what the data tells us you could
see
that you could see it really begin right
when biden took right at that exact
moment it almost seems like that's when
inflation begins on the chart anyway
and they want us to believe that this is
putin's fault
in fact here's an article from bloomberg
in january this year so this was a
couple months before the invasion began
it says u.s consumer prices soared last
year by the most in nearly four decades
so speaking of last year 2021
sapping the purchasing power of american
families and setting the stage for the
federal reserve to begin hiking interest
rates as soon as march the consumer
price index climbed seven percent in
2021 the largest 12-month gain since
june 1982 according to labor department
data released wednesday the widely
followed inflation gauge rose 0.5
percent from november exceeding forecast
so this is from the beginning of january
they're saying the year before
consumer prices were soaring
and so this
rise had already begun
and you see in almost when i say rise
it's like a vertical
it's pointed vertically all the way up
and that had begun
you know a year before more than a year
before
putin's invasion began
and they're hoping
the bite administration
thinks that we're all a bunch of morons
and they're hoping that we just forget
about everything that happened before
this past march
they just forget about the fact that we
were
even if you don't follow um the economy
that closely
we were talking about inflation and
problems with inflation and gas prices
rising before that people were noticing
it and feeling it
before that
they're hoping that we just forget about
it
and the problem is that
um
their hopes will not be entirely in vain
for a lot of people
and it's not because people are dumb i
mean there are plenty of dumb people out
there especially the ones that happen to
vote democrat
but also
we just we have the memories of fruit
flies
because we're so distracted and we're
there there's so many you know we have
so many informational inputs coming in
all the time
and uh so you're you're overwhelmed by
information every single day and that's
how we quickly forget things that
happened even a few days ago
and so it's never been easier
for them to pull a trick like this
to take this phenomenon which had which
had begun
before and to blame it on something that
just happened
and by the way now i know that um i said
when you look at the chart that's just
looking at the chart looking at the
graph you can see inflation which really
seems to have uh
the current spike that we're in the
middle of right now seems to have
started around the time when biden took
office that's what the graphs tell us
does that mean
that biden taking office caused
inflation no now biden by
administration's policies have not
helped they've only made it worse
but this also is not because of joe
biden that we're having inflation right
now
um
you know the fed has been
printing money money hand over fist for
years
and then you could go back to when the
lockdowns
began you know when the lockdown started
they shut down the economy
and then they started printing even more
money
and handing out checks to people whether
they needed it or not
and when they started doing that two
years ago many of us
because this this is another thing that
you didn't need to have a degree in
economics to understand
you shut down the economy you start
printing money you start handing money
out to people
you're
you are going to have you're going to
have to pay the price for that in a very
literal sense
those chickens are going to come home to
roost eventually
and i think a lot of people thought that
well they did all of this and then the
economy kind of opened back back up
again and at first it seemed all right
and so i think people just thought well
i guess we got away with that one
no there's a little bit of lag time
and right now the shutdown the kovidge
shutdown and the coveted stimulus
chickens are coming home to roost and
that's a big part of what we're
experiencing right now
that was entirely foreseeable
which means it's not just biden's fault
it's also his fault and it's also the
democrat party's fault but the plenty of
republicans were on board with this as
well
all right
let's see
we also have this i thought this was uh
this was interesting so over in saudi
arabia they apparently have
their own
comedy sketch shows and that sort of
thing so this went viral yesterday
here's a here's some sort of
comedy sketch show in saudi arabia
making fun of
joe biden this is how you know that
we're really being respected on the
world stage remember when they told us
that we got it we got to get rid of
trump we got to get biden in there so
that we could be respected on the world
stage again
we're very worried about
how we're perceived on the world stage
at least some people seem to be the
media thinks that we should be concerned
about that personally i don't really
care that much
um i don't wake up a bit every day
worried about how other countries see us
doesn't really bother me i don't i don't
care actually
but that was one of the arguments that
we were given for putting biden in there
is that we will be respected on the
world stage again so you watch this and
tell me
does it seem that we are being respected
is this is this what respect on the
world stage looks like let's uh let's
watch
thank you very much
today
we're going to talk about the crisis in
spain
yeah we're going to talk about the
crisis in africa
yeah russia yeah russia
and i want to talk about the
president of russia
putin yeah
putin
listen to me i have very important
message to you
the messages
and the president of china
we didn't finish russia yes sir thank
you to correct me first lady
thank you very much
god bless you and god bless
thank you all
hallelujah glad to be president go out
to a prison right now
it's pretty good that's better it's
better than snl at least that's a better
biden impersonation than we get on snl
uh and i gotta say
their camala
is a dead ringer their camille
impersonator is
i'm pretty sure a man
but he's also a dead ringer for camille
harris so that's that's how we are seen
on the world stage if you're worried
about that that's how they're that's how
we're being perceived right now um
and although i said that i don't really
care how the world perceives us
um i guess i should amend that slightly
it's not so much that i care about being
respected by other countries whatever
that would even mean
um
but the perception
does matter just in the sense that if
they if they perceive
if other countries perceive
that we are being run by a dementia
patient if they perceive correctly that
we're being run by a dementia patient
who is
totally oblivious and has no idea what's
going on well that perception
on the world stage especially by our
enemies is a is a national security
crisis so
as it relates to our national security i
guess i do care about that
i do care about the fact that um our
enemies can look and see
that um
this is who's driving the car right now
all right this is from the daily wire it
says florida republican governor ron
desantis signed a bill on monday to
provide more than 70 million dollars to
support fatherhood in his state desantis
penned the recently passed bill during a
live stream video on monday morning
house bill 7065 passed in the state
senate in march unanimously following a
117-0 unanimous vote in the house
the bill will require quote the
department of children and families
department of juvenile justice to
identify and meet the the needs of duly
involved children
within a specified time frame
requiring prenatal and infant health
care delivery programs to include
certain father engagement activities
requiring the department of children and
families to contract for the development
and implementation of the responsible
fatherhood initiative and to provide
grants to community-based
not-for-profit organizations to offer
certain mentorship programs
um and designated the month of june as
responsible fatherhood month well the
month of june is already i believe gay
pride month so but we you know
now it's gonna be designated responsible
fatherhood month
maybe a little bit of an irony there i
don't know we won't get too deeply into
it um
but i i much prefer that i think
responsible fatherhood month you know
how about a whole year dedicated to that
and this is um
this is an important thing that they're
doing down in florida i mean it's it's
one important thing after another kind
of um
batting a thousand right now at the
moment with some of these policies and
and laws that are going into effect
and yeah you're not going to you're not
going to solve the fatherhood crisis
in america with
with 70 million dollars and i could
solve it with any amount of money
whatsoever because at its base the
fatherhood crisis the fatherless home
crisis which is affecting
all communities and it's a problem
that's not getting any better um
fundamentally that's a problem of
men
having kids and choosing not to stay
home and raise their their kids
and it's not just men responsible for
that either
it's also in many cases women
who decide that their kids don't really
need a father around they don't need no
man and so on
so this is a joint effort
between men and women to create
fatherless homes and children are
growing up in broken homes
i think
what's important about what they're
doing in florida and other other states
is at least it's it's just directing
some of the attention
to where it should go
and yeah there's some money too and the
money's fine but the main thing i think
even more than the money is attention
it's focusing people's attention on this
problem
um
because we aren't going to solve
anything we're not going to have any
cultural societal improvements
until we start at the home
and the fact is we've got millions of
kids being raised right now in homes
without fathers and it turns out that um
kids actually need their fathers just
like they need their mothers
parents you know we're not we're not
interchangeable parts
the the family unit is not like mr
potato head doll which is not even a mr
potato doll anymore i guess it's just a
potato head doll where you could just
change out the parts and everything and
it's all and it'll all be fine
the family is structured a certain way
by nature
by god
and if you get outside of that structure
there there are serious consequences
so it's good that we that we are
focusing on that at least or or or
to the extent that we can redirect our
attention to that problem uh i think is
a very good thing you know tony dungy by
the way was he's the former nfl coach he
was on hand for the signing because he's
been outspoken about this issue um about
the problem of fatherless homes which is
really important and you need men at
that level with some kind of cultural
credibility he's a guy with from you
know coming from the nfl and everything
talking about this problem so he was on
hand for the signing just kind of
supporting the bill
and um
the left noticed that and they were not
happy about it so
a lot of big accounts on twitter were
attacking tony dungy the palmer report
for example says tony dungy revealed his
true self a few years ago when he said
he wouldn't want an openly gay player on
his team so of course he's appearing
alongside anti-lgbt extremist ron
desantis when people tell you who they
are believe them the first time
david dennis jr said tony dungy exactly
who we thought he was
um of course keith olbermann
was very upset
spoiler alert i worked with him tony
dungy's reputation is not spotless and
his michael sam comments disqualified
him from being considered an example of
loving loving fatherhood
and a lot of other tweets like that very
upset at tony dungy
because he's associating himself with
ron desantis
and why is he associating himself around
the census well just because there is a
actually in florida a bipartisan effort
it seems to support fathers
but you can't do that especially if
you're going to associate with rhonda
saints at the same time i want to play
this phrase so this was interesting this
is um
another contribution from uh libs of
tick tock well
it was tick tock didn't contribute this
but at least found this and show this to
us so here's a viral video of someone
explaining
why you should use
her pronouns
but i think the reason that we get is is
kind of interesting listen
you got so close to the point and then
ran away from it as soon as my boyfriend
tried to explain it to you so try and
explain more now i guess
the point is we want people to put in
the emotional effort to see us as we
actually are because what you've
described is a situation where somebody
is
memorizing pronouns rather than
actually trying to see the person in a
new light with the new information i
don't want you to see me as a woman and
then remember to use he him pronouns i
want you to see me as a dude you know
and when it's a situation like i
described in this last video i see it as
you seeing them as a cis person and just
taking the any pronouns as a cop-out to
any of the emotional work
the point is empathy
do the emotional work so that's that's
really important because this is always
the case with the left that we have to
we have to at a certain point come to
understand
is that it's it's never it always starts
with this so we're seeing the same we've
seen this this same
pattern over and over again and now
we're seeing with a pronoun thing which
yeah it it begins with the first thing
that they that they ask and
initially they do pretend that they're
just asking
uh where they say well you just will you
respect the way that i want to be
identified and it doesn't doesn't mean
i'm not encroaching on you i'm not
imposing anything on you but just
respect me when you're talking about me
can you like what what is it
what is it to you what's the big deal i
you know i have a certain a certain word
that i prefer and why can't you just use
that word no big deal right
and um
they start that way they start by asking
and then we graduate very quickly to
telling
no i'm not asking anymore i'm demanding
it
and if you don't do as i say then you
know if you're in canada for example you
might go to jail for it so we're gonna
put laws in place
and they're advocating for laws like
that in the united states
anti-conversion therapy laws because now
to misgender someone by using their
biologically correct pronoun that's
conversion therapy so you gotta you know
we're gonna there'll be legal penalties
for that and if there aren't legal
penalties they're gonna we're gonna kick
you off of uh social media platforms and
all the rest of it
so you go from asking to telling but
then you get to the point where
okay
even if
you're doing exactly as you're told
and you're being obedient and you're
cooperating
that is still not enough
because now yeah you you have the the
verbal ascent
that they are demanding
but now they're going to peer inside
your heart and soul and they want to
know
that you actually believe
don't just say
what they want you to say believe what
they want you to believe
it's your requirement to actually
believe it
so they're going to try to get inside
your mind
and tinker with it
to change the way that you actually
perceive reality
how quickly we went from ah what's a big
deal it's no big deal just say a word
doesn't matter that's all
yeah just be polite how quickly we would
go from that to
um
you must adjust
your perception of reality for my sake
and as things perpetually speed up in
our in our culture um
we graduate from just asking to telling
to even that's not enough
you know you you you must actually
believe and celebrate we go it used to
take a few years to travel that path and
now it's like a few months
and all of it is entirely foreseeable
on a similar subject here this from the
post-millennial says a biological male
inmate imprisoned for life for
strangling a cellmate to death in 2004
and previously identified as a
transgender woman is now demanding to be
treated like a baby by prison staff and
wants to be given diapers and baby food
according to the daily record 36 year
old convicted killer sophie eastwood
formerly known as daniel was sentenced
to prison for life back in 2004 after
strangling cellmate paul algie with
shoelaces
eastwood has been jailed at dumfries
young offenders institution at 18 for
dangerous driving and then strangled and
killed someone now he's in jail for life
uh in 2016 eastwood then claimed to be a
woman
originally he said he's a a gay man and
then he said well okay it turns out i'm
actually a woman and this was in a
psychologist session in prison
and
so i guess the psychologists we've got a
guy who's in prison
for for murdering somebody and uh he
says oh i'm actually a woman and then
the the highly trained psychologist says
oh i guess you are
you couldn't you couldn't possibly be
wrong about who you are but you you
certainly couldn't tell any lies or just
a convicted murderer is all
um
and so eastwood has been jailed in a
women's prison since 2018 and takes a
testosterone blocking drug
again follow the follow the trajectory
there it makes a lot of sense right
you've got a convicted murderer
obviously a dangerous person
says i'm a woman
and then immediately it's well you you
couldn't possibly be wrong you couldn't
be deluded
you couldn't be lying and uh why not
just put you to women's prison
it's not like you've demonstrated
yourself to be a violent dangerous
person
and so they got he got exactly what he
wants every step of the way of course
and um now he identifies
rather than a woman more specifically he
identifies as a baby
and demands diapers and baby food from
the prison staff
i guess there's a question about
whether he identifies as a
as a female baby i'm not exactly sure
but he he identifies as a baby and he's
being given
that's how he's being treated by prison
staff
there is there's there's no end to it
once you
remove yourself from reality and you
start to if you you declare that we have
to affirm someone's alleged
self-perception
uh no matter how
far that self-perception is from reality
of course there's no end to
it i mean why not just release him from
prison i guess if he's a baby then uh he
like who puts babies in prison this is a
this is a human rights violation
i mean can you imagine but he identifies
as a he identifies us
as a one-year-old
what kind of backwards
society would put a one-year-old in
prison for god's sake
so just release him from releasing from
prison entirely why not
all right i want to play this for you
too um cam newton is a free agent
quarterback in the nfl and he was
trending yesterday for some comments he
made
in an interview
that have upset a lot of people let's
listen to those
i had a perfect
a perfect example of what a man was in
my life by my father my parents have
been together for 36 37 years now and
it's and it's a beautiful thing
uh i grew up in a three-parent household
my mom my father and my grandmother
and uh i knew what
a woman was not a bad
okay what's the difference a woman okay
a bad is
a person who's just
you know
girl i'm a bad [ __ ] you know i'm doing
this i'm doing that i i
i looked apart
but i don't act the part okay you know
and it's a lot of women who are bad
and i say
in a way not to degrade a woman
but
just to to to go off the aesthetic of
what they deem as a boss chick now
a woman for me is
handling your own but knowing how to
cater to
a man's needs
right
and i think a lot of times when you get
that aesthetic of like i'm a boss
like i'm a dis i'm a dad no baby like
but you can't cook
okay you don't know you don't know when
to be quiet you don't know how to allow
a man to lead
can't say those things these days
that is uh highly offensive i mean even
though he's he's saying something that
you know almost every
man in history can relate to to a
certain extent
um
well you can't you can't say those
things now you have to keep in mind that
cam newton he says that he learned how
to be a man and all that kind of thing
uh i don't think he's exactly
the role model for
a good father and a good man i think he
has he's got kids by several different
women and all that kind of stuff
so not exactly
not a lot of room to talk
not exactly himself a role model for men
but of course what he's what he's
talking about well you know you you want
a woman who
understands a man's needs just like a
man should understand a woman's needs in
fact if you go further into that clip
there's another clip that it cuts off
right there he continues talking he
talks about how men should be catering
to the needs of women and so there
should be this kind of what he's trying
to get to you have to decipher it a
little bit but he's trying to get to is
the complementary nature of the
man-woman relationship and um he wants
he wants a woman has some of those kind
of
feminine characteristics god forbid
um
but you just uh you just can't talk
about that anymore um and so you've got
you've got a a lot of people who are
you know
confused and they want certain things
out of relationships we talk a lot about
the situation that single people are in
especially younger single people
and how horrendous the dating scene is
right now
and one of the many things that makes it
so difficult is that you've got
men and women
who sort of naturally want certain
things out of relationships but they
can't even talk about what those things
are
because they're they're told that it's
it's shameful so if you're a man and you
want a feminine woman god forbid you
want you'd like a woman who can cook or
something
you can't talk about that it's a
shameful thing you're told
so you're not supposed to want that
well then what are you supposed to want
exactly
well the culture doesn't provide any
answers there so you're just sort of
stuck in neutral
speaking of bad marriages i've had this
clip that before i get to comment
section i think we'll just play very
quickly
um
i think i did promise we would not
return to the will smith slap gate and
we're not we're not going all the way
back to slap gate but
i did
last week as we got to the end of the
slap gate discourse i did make the point
that you know i think the real villain
in that whole thing
will smith is responsible for his
actions which were insane but the real
villain i think is jada pickett smith
his wife and just kind of
i think reinforcing that point here's a
video
that uh resurface i don't know when it's
from it's from a few years ago i think
of uh will smith and his wife and just
watch this you kind of see what their
marriage is all about
you know stan perella's coming to the
table she's gonna be at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness if you
confess
come help us again please
i'm still dealing with foolishness don't
no no she yeah because she don't just
would you say that she helped us heal
the hurts that we caused between one
another my social media presence is my
bread and butter okay so you can't just
use me for social media and not
you know don't just start bro i'm
standing in my house
don't just start rolling
please watch a stare at the red table
because she's helped us a lot can't you
tell
that's actually hard to watch i i i
actually feel a little sorry for the guy
i gotta say
i mean you gotta stand up for yourself
as a man in your relationship and he
clearly has not done that
but uh that's now you you can relate
like i think every man is in this
position where
you know
the woman pulls out the the phone wants
to take a picture or whatever
um and i know me it's like i i never i'm
never in a position where i actually
want to take a picture that's like
that's the bane of my wife's existence
because if it were up to me would there
be no except for this show and what i do
for there'd be no footage of me anywhere
um so there is a little bit of this you
know this push and pull in a
relationship
but when your husband clearly says i
don't want to be on camera and you keep
shoving it in his face i think that kind
of shows
where that relationship is
but he needs to
he's this this is a not that i can give
um it's probably too late to give
marriage advice anyway but
at a certain point
you have to stand up for yourself a
little bit in your relationship which i
don't think he's uh ever done pretty
clearly
well you heard the big announcement a
couple weeks ago two announcements
actually what is a woman the movie and
what is the woman book the book which
are both coming very soon the movie's
coming in may the book is coming in june
uh there's still so much that we cannot
tell you about these projects we really
can't tell you almost anything about
them
except what you get from the title and
the teaser which you can find at
whatiswoman.com you can pre-order the
book a lot more on both these projects
coming very very soon but go to
whatisawoman.com uh pre-order the book
watch the teaser uh more on the way and
we also have this coming which is just
tomorrow where we are a little over a
year into joe biden's presidency and
it's been nothing short of a disaster
from gas prices to the war in ukraine
safe to say the leader of the free world
is not up to the challenge not only that
but massive corporations like disney are
showing us what they really have in mind
for our future generations which is
complete leftist indoctrination that's
why you should tune in to catch an
all-new episode of us discussing what's
happening and how we're actively
fighting it on backstage tomorrow with
myself ben shapiro jeremy board michael
knowles and andrew clavin it streams
tomorrow at seven o'clock uh eastern 6
pm central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel dailywire don't want to
miss it if you're not a member yet head
to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code build the future
for enormous 45 off your membership
today
let's get now to the comment
section do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
this is from colson duggan says matt
your destruction of the smug
libertarians was quite good however i
don't think you fully refuted the last
points i'm curious to hear you
articulate your position better her
description of her pervasive obsessive
anxiety was definitely abnormal and
irrational
my wife suffers from the same thing so
i've heard it i've seen it firsthand i
do agree that we shouldn't just jump to
drugs to address the problem but i would
definitely say it is a disorder it is
most certainly not normal i have quite
literally never experienced the kind of
anxiety that my wife experiences because
my fears lack the obsessive component
that she has i can also see a noticeable
difference in my wife
when she gets her serotonin levels up
while i agree that general fears are not
a disorder and i think you've pretty
much convinced me about adhd as well
this kind of anxiety that she describes
is a disorder it's just been
misclassified as generalized anxiety
disorder
rather than what it is a subset of
obsessive-compulsive disorder interested
to hear
your thoughts
uh well the last thing that you said i
could um have to think more about it but
i could maybe go along with that um
i have said this before when we talk
about some of these mental illnesses
that i don't think are actually our
mental illnesses like adhd for example
i do think that what's going on is
many times you have normal
behaviors normal emotions and so on
personality traits that are just
medicalized and categorized as a
as a mental condition when they're not
and but but i think i think that that
explains
a huge portion of these cases
and then what about the smaller portion
that cannot be explained that way i
think some of them probably have been
miscategorized i'm not taking the
position that mental illnesses don't
exist at all
i just think that our
we need to recalibrate
how we view mental illnesses and start
and and maybe start from a real basic
level
of defining what exactly they are
which i don't think we've done
and once we have that conversation then
i think we're still going to be left
with with some mental illnesses not 300
like they have in the dsm right now but
some
i mean so you take for example like uh
an obvious one i think would be a
schizophrenic uh or someone who's who's
hallucinating and that that kind of
thing look clearly
this is this is someone who's for lack
of a better term crazy right what we
used to just call crazy how we say
mental illness so that category exists
i'm not saying your wife is a
schizophrenic but you have that sort of
category
and um i think that's a pretty small
category in comparison to the 300 mental
illnesses that we have right now
and so you say some of these cases are
are just miscategorized i don't
necessarily disagree with you it sounds
like you don't really disagree with me
because i am i am skeptical of the
diagnosis of generalized anxiety
disorder and if you're saying
that um
you've seen a disorder
characterized this way
that clearly is a disorder but you think
it should be categorized should be put
in a different category then i don't
think there's much of a disagreement
there
um the thing with anxiety is
going back to anxiety and not ocd
it is as i argued yesterday
a
basic
fact
of the human condition
you know uh schizophrenia hallucinations
hearing voices in your head
those sorts of things that's not a basic
fact of the human condition that is very
clearly inarguably
uh
abnormal that's outside of what what is
what it what is uh you know
normal
but anxiety is is part of the the human
condition
and i say that all anxiety is pervasive
in the sense that like
i don't think there's anyone walking
around
on earth who's just entirely free of
anxiety
i don't think that exists
so if you have something that's
fundamental to human nature
and that is pervasive in the sense that
everyone experiences it to some degree
kind of all the time it's always there
at least bubbling under the surface you
have your anxieties whatever they are
that you carry around with you you might
not obsess over them but you have them
and to take that and to try to
medicalize it
kind of by degree and say well okay
here's where anxieties normally are but
then if you get above this arbitrary
line now it's a medical condition
i'm very skeptical of that
and the problem is that because the line
is so arbitrary when you do that you're
going to end up with a whole bunch of
people
who get diagnosed with mental illnesses
who should not be
which is what we're seeing right now
uh let's see
brandon says
i honestly don't know many doctors who
guess and keep their license for too
long yeah we heard yesterday that the
doctors look at babies and just they
don't even assign sex anymore now the
new languages they just guess about
whether the
baby's boy or girl and i thought about
that after the show yesterday
when we had this first grade teacher
telling
students that that's the way it works
when babies are born that they just the
doctors just guess that's all
but then the teacher admits that most of
the time the guess is right
it's only a minority of occasions when
the guess is wrong
well i'd like to hear that person
explain why exactly
the guess is usually right
is it because the quote-unquote guess is
being based on
some kind of physical reality some
significant physical reality could that
be the case
we'll see
um
let's see
uh and alicia says i can't wait for the
episode where matt reacts to the
libertarians reacting to him
reacting to them reacting to him pure
gold oh we're gonna it's this is just an
inception now of reactions and it's
gonna it will continue you can be sure
of that speaking of which let's get to
the daily cancellation
[Music]
yesterday for this segment of the show
we spent approximately four and a half
hours responding to a couple of obscure
libertarian youtubers may have seemed
like overkill but then again if you
listen frequently you know that i could
easily do an entire show on one tick
tock video that annoyed me so it's all
par for the course today for our daily
cancellation we're gonna
uh we're going somewhere slightly less
obscure but still libertarian i hadn't
planned to dump on the libertarians so
much this week but that's the way it's
working out and
i think i find libertarians so
especially annoying because
we have a few significant things in
common
and yet ultimately they're still so
wrong when it comes down to it and
that's where the frustration comes from
for me
the libertarians are singing my tune
when they talk about abolishing the
income tax or
massively decreasing the size of the
federal government
they tend to be skeptical of the
government education system which is
good and protective of gun rights
they are generally pretty consistent
constitutionalists all of these things
are good they may take it a bit too far
sometimes
like not all taxation is theft for
example just most of it is but still we
line up pretty closely on those issues
things fall apart when we move from
economic and strictly constitutional
issues over to
cultural and moral concerns
here libertarianism begins to quickly
break apart
and the libertarian is left out in the
cold in the dark confused not sure which
way to go
his ideology is not robust enough to
account for the full scope of the human
experience
he was mostly right about those economic
constitutional issues but he was right
for if not the wrong reasons that at
least incomplete reasons
he wants to pay fewer taxes and keep his
guns and so on because of liberty and by
liberty he simply means
his own personal ability to do whatever
he wants because he wants to do it
there are fuller and sturdier reasons to
be in favor of gun rights and against
over taxation
but those generally are not his reasons
and so when he encounters the deeper
issues the moral issues he has only his
kind of
libertine do what you want mentality to
fall back on
this is when he starts shouting slogans
like let people enjoy things and the
government shouldn't legislate morality
except that literally all legislation
legislates morality
all laws by definition are rooted in a
moral code
they may be wrongly rooted or rooted in
the wrong moral code but completely
amoral laws would be laws passed without
concern at all for whether they're
actually right or wrong
legislation that doesn't attempt to
legislate morality would be by
definition arbitrary
the libertarian doesn't seem to fully
understand this fact and as for letting
people enjoy things the fact is that
enjoyment is not in and of itself
enough
to justify
any act
if we're determining whether an act
should be legal or even simply whether
it's good aside from the legal question
we need to ask more than just do people
enjoy it
and when it comes to that enjoyment we
also need to reflect on the nature of
the act and consider the sort of
pleasure that's being derived from it
take almost any self-destructive and
harmful act and you'll find people who
enjoy it
that is they take pleasure however
however twisted from it
should we simply leave people to their
self-destructive pleasures even if the
pursuit of that pleasure is actually
making them miserable and causing
despair in the long run
these are all questions that
libertarianism cannot answer and refuses
to even consider
and that long preamble brings us to an
article in the libertarian reason
magazine written by writer elizabeth
nolan brown titled the new campaign for
a sex-free internet it's a lengthy
article that can't be fully analyzed in
this segment but the basic gist is that
brown is upset about the fact that due
to rule changes over at sites like
pornhub
fewer amateur wannabe porn stars are
able to [ __ ] themselves and their
bodies out for a quick buck
brown is deeply concerned that there is
now a tragic scarcity of whoring on the
internet so reading out says for more
than a decade both amateurs and
professionals shared their sometimes
sweet sometimes weird and often graphic
sexual activity on pornhub
launched in 2007 not long after youtube
and with a similar free-for-all spirit
the site represented a new wave of adult
entertainment in which anyone with an
internet connection could partake and
anyone with a digital camera could
become a star now a quick sidebar here
we have already started on a precarious
note with the writer's claim that the
graphic sexual content on pornhub is
sometimes sweet
i would have thought that sweet would be
something like i don't know bringing
flowers home for your wife just because
i wouldn't think of it as like humping
somebody on camera and posting it to the
internet for profit
maybe i just have an old-fashioned sense
of romance probably so
continuing
dubbed tube sites pornhub and its
various peers began to dominate web
traffic generally in porn consumption
specifically these sites
trod on porn's established business
model but for savvy sex workers the tube
site network could provide a way to
break into the business or reach
audiences directly without the porn
industry's usual middlemen
to monetize one's presence in the early
days took some creativity but tube sites
would eventually offer content
partnerships that allowed people to get
paid directly for their videos
their competitors such as cam sites and
clip stores made the process of charging
money and getting paid even smoother
oh yes just kind of reflecting
nostalgically on the good old days
brown here speaks wistfully and
longingly about the time when many
thousands or even millions of people
um who would have otherwise been shut
out of the porn industry were able to
break into it with the help of the
internet monetizing their sexual
activity and auctioning their bodies off
to the highest bidder or the lowest
bidder or just any bitter at all
in previous generations you know some of
those people
unable to become porn stars
may have ended up
getting an education instead or training
somewhere taking up a trade becoming
entrepreneurs
entering some other more productive
profession
but pornhub saved them from that dark
path
and that was very good brown says
because
quote
for the first time people with a truly
diverse array of body types looks races
ethnicity sexuality gender identities
and kinks had direct access to the tools
of porn production and distribution
in the past porn had catered to a much
more narrow range of tastes with
predictable results
now audiences could access all sorts of
content
that defied conventional notions
conventional notions of who and what was
deserving of lust
on sites like pornhub and the
microblogging platform tumblr outside
the mainstream content thrived
now we'll return to that passage in just
a moment
but first let's continue on a little
farther as we get to the tragic moments
where everything fell apart and this is
the moment that brown so deeply laments
it says quote and then one day it was
gone in december 2020 without warning
pornhub removed all videos posted by
unverified users a massive cachet of
content encompassing anything not posted
by formal content partners or members of
the platform's official model program
more than 10 million videos were
suspended and unverified users were
banned from uploading or downloading new
videos
it was more than a disruption to the
site i almost feel like we need sad
piano music in the background here the
unannounced disappearing of so many
videos was a huge cultural loss says
ashley a transgender sex worker and
civil rights activist with a robust
presence on social media often and in
offline organizing
the pornhub purge came about two years
after tumblr's ban on any content
depicting sex acts and preceded a
similar announcement in summer 2021 from
only fans
then in september 2021 the first user
uploaded uploaded pornsite x-tube
founded in 2006 and now owned by the
same parent company
shut down entirely
tragedy
now there are still billions of smut
videos online but it's uh i mean
literally billions of them
but it's a huge cultural loss
that we're missing a few of them now she
says
she um mourns over the fact that prior
to all of these
amateur cyber prostitutes being kicked
out of the club
porn was on its way to being truly
equitable with a diverse array of body
types looks races ethnicities
sexualities etc etc all represented by
porn
now what's of course lost in this is any
sense of what is actually good
the writer being a dedicated libertarian
doesn't concern herself with such
questions
instead she simply declares that if
people are doing a certain thing
and if they seem to be deriving any
pleasure from it
then it's best if everyone is able to do
it equally and equitably
the fact that whoring yourself on the
internet brings despair and hopelessness
and leads so often to substance abuse
and suicide is irrelevant to her
if a group of people are marching off of
a cliff
and they seem to have smiles on their
faces while they're doing it she just
wants to make sure that the group is
demographically representative of the
overall population
again the concept of the good what is
good
is lost
and that is always lost
by libertarians and and generally by the
culture
and of course what one of their
rejoinders here what are the responses
is well who defines good what is good
how can you define that
yeah we do have to talk about what the
good means
but um are you saying that a word like
liberty or freedom or human rights
is that any clearer to you than good
run into the same problem how do you
define that
it's not like there's some sort of
unanimous agreement on what any of those
words mean
in fact the fact that we cannot agree on
what those words means is like tearing
our culture apart right now
but and so instead they just rather than
talking about what good means and uh
concerning themselves whether they just
discard it entirely let's not even worry
about what's actually good
and that brings us to the most revealing
phrase of all that we get in that in
that article which is deserving of lust
deserving of lust
now
i can see why people would want to be
deserving of love
love is fulfilling it's edifying
there is joy in love in fact there isn't
joy anywhere but in love there's no joy
outside of love
but lust by itself
is the reduction of a person to the
level of an object
that's what lust is especially the lust
uh in that you find with pornography on
the internet
the person who's doing the lusting they
don't recognize the image on the screen
they don't see that person as a person
it's just an object that is there to
gratify them
that is lust down to its basis level
it's
objectification
treating a person like an object
if you're an object of lust apart from
love
then you're being coveted the way that a
person might covet a consumer good like
a car or a new pair of shoes
should this actually be anyone's goal
the fact that certain people are being
deprived of the opportunity to be
objectified by strangers on the internet
to be treated like an object
absent of their of their personhood
is this something that we should be
striving for
is it a tragedy that people are being
deprived of it
do we have a right to it
well this is the kind of nonsense that
libertarianism so often descends into
and that is ultimately why
um the writer of this article whose name
i've already forgotten last name brown
is today canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
[Music]
godspeed the matte wall show is produced
by sean hampton executive producer
jeremy boring our supervising producer
is mathis glover production manager pavo
valdoski our associate producer is
mckenna waters the show is edited by
robbie dantzler our audio is mixed by
mike coromina and hair and makeup is
done by cherokee heart the matte wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 22. the u.s
suffers quote extraordinarily elevated
inflation elon musk decides not to join
twitter's board of directors don't worry
what he's doing is actually even better
and we have just found out
very possibly one of the main reasons
that disney is trying to trans the kids
check it out on the michael knowles show
you